our series of more perfect union names
to show that what unites us as americans
is far greater than what divides us as
the number of coronavirus cases soars at
colleges and universities
and campuses shut down many students are
struggling
to meet basic needs like finding a safe
place to live
and enough food to eat meg oliver shows
us how one small college in the south
is helping students with nowhere to go
did you want me to put it under one of
the homework drop boxes sophomore
michaela alston is determined to
graduate from benedict college in
columbia south carolina
even after finding herself homeless
during the pandemic
i was terrified so i just prayed i'd
rather be
homeless than to be in a toxic situation
when campus shut down march 18th
michaela says she was out of options
in an effort to avoid an abusive home
life michaela
searched for abandoned parking lots to
sleep in her car
at night i wanted to give up spent days
crying and moping
it was very challenging you know having
to get up and
find a place to brush your teeth during
the day the 19-year-old who earned a
full academic scholarship worked two
jobs and hunted for internet access to
complete her studies
so it was very challenging trying to get
school work done and maneuvering two
jobs and everything
it was hard michaela finally reached out
to her professors for help which sparked
an alert system on campus
jamila lynn is the director of
specialized programming
she was in a dire place she definitely
had housing and security
she needed food she needed basic
necessities campus was closed but lynn
quickly arranged to take care of
michaela's needs including
a safe place to stay for so many of our
students benedict college is the safe
place
and so to be asked to leave that space
put a number of our students at risk
benedict is a small historically black
college
about 80 percent of their students are
dependent on financial aid
about 40 percent like michaela are first
generation students
when kovid closed campus the
administration
raised enough money within 36 hours to
send everyone home
but they didn't realize home was not an
option
for many we were shocked quite frankly
at the number of students who
manifested housing and security issues
food and security issues and so we spent
a great deal of the summer
facilitating those requests funding
those requests and in some instances
even negotiating
leases short-term housing situations and
in some very limited instances shelter
placement
during the early days of the pandemic
one survey found
15 percent of students at four-year
institutions were homeless
benedict estimates for them that at
least 24 percent of their student body
faces housing insecurity and depend on
living with extended family or friends
part of the challenge that we face is
students willingness to open up and
share
the difficulties that they're
experiencing so perhaps you're telling
her story will encourage other students
to step up and say i need help too
did benedict college save you yes
oh my goodness yes yes if i did not send
that email i
i don't know where i would have been
right now how does your future look
today
i have a mission which is to obtain my
degree
and upon graduation commission in the
united states air force so
i feel like i have a really bright
future i just have to keep my head on
a straight for cbs this morning meg
oliver
to keep
hats off to her what an incredible young
woman what a rock star
yeah and what an amazing job this
college is doing helping those kids
and a lot of colleges are doing it
because as more kids go to school that
didn't used to
you have more of these issues and they
need that extra support if you're going
to finish the mission yeah i think this
this was a really powerful story because
i don't think a lot of people realize
the position those kids are
still with michaela alston yeah you have
a great bright future